bonjour à tous alors ça y est on change
de siècle et on va parler un nouveau
joueur
c'est alexandra les kin donc joueurs nés
en russie un liquide donc est né vers
moscou à moscou en 1892 et avocat basé
sa jeunesse il a appris les achats que
l'âge de 7 ans et puis jouer un peu avec
son frère ce terrain il a pas mal de jeu
par correspondance puis il a lancé sa
carrière petit à petit mais c'est vite
la lra sèment assez talentueux quoi et
donc dans les premières vidéos sur ali
keane
beh compter un peu montré partie de sa
jeunesse comme pas encore le grand
joueur qui va devenir mais comment il
est monté en puissance et c est donc à
noter voilà donc tu as les quines et
russes mais qui a demandé la nationalité
française plus tard il est devenu
français en 1927
même s'il vivait depuis un petit moment
je crois qu'il est parti de russie
d'après ce que j'ai lu vers 1921 il ya
des problèmes un peu je crois le régime
communiste et donc il a préféré fuir il
a été deux fois arrêté la fille de fer
virtuel fallu plus d'une histoire c'est
en convoi la sq en fait aussi une fois
en 1914 il jouait le un tournoi à
mannheim en allemagne et après mondiale
éclate en plein milieu du tournoi et il
s'est fait arrêter la bande allemagne ou
limiter accusé justement d'être un agent
double russe qui venait espionné là
enfin vide assez mouvementée mais
finalement il s'en est sorti
il a fallu faire sa carrière dont deux
joueurs d'échecs voilà ben écoutez si
tous ces détails historiques vous
intéresse toujours le notés en dessous
et puis j'essaierai de faire un détail
un exposé un peu plus détaillée juste
fait en gros mais donc voilà est donc la
première partie qu'on m'a regardée par
daily qin en 1907
donc il ya d'autres parties de lui avant
disponible mais surtout par
correspondance mais donc je préfère
prendre une partie de tournoi normale
entre guillemets france d'échecs
voilà donc en 1907 où mon adversaire qui
s'appelle isakov constantin et
et puis on va voir ça don kelly qui
n'allait blanc et la jouer aux cartes
ok donc le 4-4 premier coup son
adversaire cinq cavaliers pts 3 kelly c6
et c5 et une ouverture en génie ces
trois donc ces trois pas très vu comme
coup quelque part mais
apparence assez logique en fait on a un
pion pour contrôler des quatre et on
veut jouer là nous mêmes des quatre
ensuite écrire un gros centre de cure
alors le défaut c'est quoi on valoir
dans la partie c'est soit que les noirs
ajouté cinq comme ils l'ont fait et donc
nous attaquent immédiatement le centre
blanc parce que le truc c'est qu'après
puis on prend dame prend ben on n'a pas
en plus de coûter ok ces trois axes très
pénible qu'on doit occuper la case par
un pion il ya une autre possibilité
pendant rd57 faire cavalier m6 est
directement dans l'attaqué ce pion sur
leucate et là les blancs soit ils
feraient des trois pour le défendre les
frais quand même des quatre pour contre
attaquer ou 5 mais c'est une autre
variante alors toujours est il les dents
on fait des cinq qui a un très bon coup
et qui n'a joué badama quatre dames à 4
pas mal alors c'est l'idée de la vente
ces deux clowns cavaliers en c6 pour
pouvoir prendre le pion de 5
ok epci se défendent pions très bien se
bouture est encore faible et 5 on en
remet une couche sur le calice et 6 qui
avait jugé le 7 ok tout défendu puis on
prend dé 5,2 me prends des cinq les
blancs rock eric quénard il a joué le
petit coucou 17 très bien on coûts de
développement et puis enlève le clouage
sur le calice et six mois à rick et
blanc lait qui n'a joué des 4 et son
adversaire donc isakov a joué le coup de
4 qui est pas mauvais qui est pas
mauvais mais peut-être que ah si c'est
encore mieux
et d'ailleurs à ce n'est ni cassis vt
jouée par parra liqin lui-même donc par
correspondance en 1902 donc à l'époque
il avait juste dix ans et donc pas mal
quoi à 6 soit donc l'idée basse et sa
nasse d'un premier 5
l'adversaire a dit qu'il avait retiré
son fion ces quatre cas c'est une faute
parce qu'il a un jeu qui les prend petit
combine attaque la dame à 4 et donc sur
fou prend ici on retire le cavaliere
deux échecs comme ça sera plus en l'air
brault h1 il faut prend 1,4 et les noirs
sont clairement mieux bon il a quand
même perdu la partie en liquide mais
comme je lisais les dix ans donc ça peut
aussi se comprendre mais bon là les
dents sont beaucoup mieux
clairement clairement ouais non sur a6
normalement il faut jouer 6 4 il faut
jouer 6 4 avec les blancs et d'amd ci
semble possible mais d'un 27 pas mal
aussi
l'idée c'est que sur des cinq et un coup
bizarre qui tient le tient la baraque
c'est tour à sept alors ça cesse pour
ceux d'entre vous qui veulent vraiment
ou si la théorie et idées etc si les
blancs en caisse la pièce ici on reprend
du pian le fou a pas trop de casse de
suite font pas du tout et quand il prend
ainsi son peu le pourchasser comme ces 8
on va le gagner
donc l'un dans l'autre on a une égalité
matérielle mais la paire de chou et donc
quand on reprend à six sont à gagner
attention la dame on va enlever ce
cavalier
on va sortir le fougeux pas en deux sets
en d6 quelque part faire petit rock et
jouets pour un avantage plutôt long
terme avec les voiles à la fois c'était
le petit côté théorique mais me voilà
bon jeu qu'elle pouvait pas un ordre
quatre ça va mais là si spaemann et puis
on voit donc là avec le c4 qui prendrait
quatre que déjà très jeune il y avait
une bonne vision tactique quoi les
quines et ça a été un une de ses grandes
caractéristiques en fait il est il a
encore retenu dans l'histoire comme un
très très bon joueur d'attac
mais il a fait évoluer les choses vers
steppa joueurs d'attaqué qui se jeta à
tout va un peu comme dans l'est
les romantiques ce qu'on a vu jusqu'à
présent en fait dans vos vidéos c'était
plus construit comme jeu stérile attaqué
s'il avait le terrain pour c'était un
des premiers joueurs vraiment complet en
fait aux échecs et voilà bon bref les
normes mais voilà les 9 400 cavaliers et
cinq bien jouer normal scientifique
centre qui a vu les baies 3 directions
c5 ici et là petit coussin page de tous
les noirs cavaliers aux 5
donc l'idée bien sûr c'est que si on
prend il vous prend b5 et s'il vous
prend 17
alors alors les noirs ferait qu amélie
prend laisseraient pas leurs cavaliers
en l'air a dit qin avocats et ses 5 mai
fu prend dès cet été bien sûr possible
aussi et de superbes sûrement une petite
faute quand même de la part des noirs
qui ont fait 6 6
donc la première vue cet appel à rio
mais ça valait peut-être mieux fait
juste d'échangés et puis d'enlever ce
qui éveille emprise de ramener la
parcourir les chèques et bomba le truc
en fait c'est qu'après deux premiers
sets
en fait les orques juste prendre ici et
sida me prendrait 5 qu'elle prend des
cinq puis on prend le seae baril et noir
vont reprendre le pion avec francs et
avoir l'impression plutôt meilleure donc
ils perdaient pas le pion beyssade dans
la bataille et ouais là ils sont mieux
parce que mieux développer plus d espace
je suis en plus sympa à jouer se fout
pas remboursait pas trop trop ce qu'on
va en faire c'est un peu pénible par la
cie les anges et 5 qui va se prendre un
lâche 6 il va devoir repartir
donc c'est pas terrible on apprend
qu'ils aient des salles bien sûr les
blancs n'aura pas été objet du tout
d'aller faire d'un premier sacre c'était
juste pour illustrer et peut-être un peu
comme ces quatre où je sais pas bon car
il ya trois peut-être pour se développer
mais mais voilà c'était le meilleur son
pour les noirs toujours est il et il a
joué 6 6
alors sur quoi avec les blancs petit
gars partie de son show maintenant le
cavaly fait une sorte de mini fourchette
ici et il fait pousser 8
alors pour l'instant on peut toujours
pas prendre ce qu'est le 5 pascal qui
veut lire ces cinq ans prise mais voilà
d'avec food et c'est pour faire pousser
8 s'est jamais idéal est donc dans la
partie s'est développé avec flou 3b cinq
attaques la dame
il a bougé qui a laissé 4 mange dimpre
ans qui a aidé de gagner un temps de
développement d'un des cinq cas un bon
coup somme toute pas difficile mais bien
à 4 alors pourquoi pas ce que l'on
commence à ouvrir des lignes les noirs
on voit que sont loin d'avoir fini
redéveloppement donc alors au centre les
fous à la maison donc plus le jeu
s'ouvre plus les pièces blanches vous
pouvoir s'engouffrer et donc face à un
principe toujours très important aux
échecs privilégie 6 jouer avec les noirs
est ici ok allez qui n'a tf3 donc
pourquoi pas mais je veux dire que la
province était très bien aussi juste
prendre ses pions alors évidemment
approuvé peut-être ce que
ce qu'on peut dire c'est oui attention
y'a f4 ça va gagner le chou et 3 mai
donc il ya un tel avantage développement
que ça ne fait pas trop quoi pour les
nerfs par exemple comme ses quatre chats
seul adam disons qu'elle s'en aille
là-bas repcet les blancs pourraient
juste prendre 4 par exemple pour déjà
prendre trois pions pour la pièce a
beaucoup il ya ouais donc ça c'est très
bien on peut faire que tu comprends mais
tout arrive à 38 ans pour la pièce est
encore lui qui peut sauter les pions
centraux qui a qui arrivent peut-être
même des six tout ce pion et menacera de
le prendre part de faire baisser un jour
enfin ça vient de tous les côtés donc il
n'y avait pas vraiment de raison d'avoir
peur de de ce coût de ce couac a en tout
cas il a fait froid je suis pas sûr que
les remparts de f4 en tout cas il joua
dans cet esprit do et à la position très
bien lotis qu'une heure il a vite pris
en c5 puis on prend au moins il accélère
ses chances de pouvoir faire petit rock
et il le fait d'hommes des trois
attaques le fou fou g5 et là bas une
faute en fait il a fallu six trop
gourmand 16 ans oui voila je t'ai que le
fou qui doit défendre le cavalier et
silva quelques par ailleurs up
lecavalier a sauté d'ailleurs le foie
pas trop de casse de suite faut dire et
gourmand insiste éric ici il était temps
de penser au développement on le dit
jamais assez mais voilà on verra comment
on ne rendra pas de problème est là h6
donc mal jouer et donc à les kinois la
conduisait à vision de combinaisons et
willa et boukari 3,4 alors l'idée c'est
quoi c'est que bon il y eut siens dans
la partie mais scipion prend le 4 ils
jouent tour à des attaques la dame est
disons que la dame bouge tout de suite
on va s'en prendre aux adverse et on
voit de suite le défaut d'avoir gardé ce
roi au centre le dawa rockets et l'or
sont punis immédiatement et ça peut
mener aux maths par exemple mon truc ou
de vente illustrative échec le roi
commencent à partir en cavale tour des
six échecs
bref 5 d'alex est bon c'est une grande
comme ça du str hâtives on va prendre
les 5 dans le projet 6 course f 4 mois
endroit pareil normalement finit
toujours par sermat et la bougie 3 on
voit ici que l'on prend on prend quand
des quatre matches bon ça c'est une
variante c'est un exemple mais ça montre
le problème dont cac et pris quatre
c'est ça l'idée d'aller qu'il en fait
c'est qu'ils libèrent la colonne des
problèmes sa tour attaqué la dame et il
va menacer d'aller en des huit donc avec
les noirs il a plutôt pris en g5
mais les flics et les six échecs gers
d'irak le roi tour à des 1 bat très bien
joué un plat saddam en face durant un
canal
la tour en face de duras de la dame
pardon dame e3 et chiens croit h1 d'un
mètre quatre bombes menace m'attend h2
mais c'est assez flagrant g3 bon
maintenant la dame doit bouger ils vont
se prendre une découverte à la fed à me
prend 1,4 et aller qui n'a simplement
choqué les pro b 5 et chaque donc avec
la tour et il a enlevé le pion qui
défendent à la dame
un quiz reprendre la dame et sur quoi
son adversaire a abandonné donc eh bien
écoutez une bonne petite partie du jeu
na li qin l'a donc qui âgé de 15 ans
avant la partie et qui montrent déjà
donc un un beau style de jeu voilà moi
se retrouver pour d'autres vidéos donc
dali tin un peu dans sa jeunesse et puis
petit à petit on va suivre sa carrière
je pense étalé sur une bonne dizaine de
vidéos voire plus en fait je pense parce
que bah c'est un des joueurs qui a
compté bien sûr dans dans l'histoire des
gens français puisqu'il est devenu
champion du monde donc
donc voilà à les ébats bientôt church